this is a production of cornell
university
yeah thank you for the introduction um
do you guys hear me all right
uh if i if i stop for a read it's just
because i'm not just presenting
so i'm excited to be here um i just want
to start by saying
if you guys have any i'm an engineer i'm
used to presenting to engineers uh
so if you guys have any questions feel
free to just interrupt me raise your
hand you don't have to wait till the end
of the presentation to ask any questions
so um just out of curiosity everyone
here is applied sciences backgrounds
for backgrounds
but i guess anyone studying viticulture
in particular
okay well that's good that's good for me
so um
i just want to start by acknowledging uh
justin bennett google and kirsten
peterson
who are the pi's in this project and
security funding for ceta and uh nsf and
so yeah i just wanted to start by
acknowledging that um so i'm just gonna
give you a quick element of my
presentation i'm just gonna start by
talking a little bit about my background
and where i'm coming from and then
move into like a motivation and
background on the research project
itself
and uh go over a little bit of
terminology
for the
rest of the presentation and talk about
the traditional yield prediction methods
and why we're interested in improving
upon them uh and then from there i'll
sort of lay out the proposed method that
we're researching and go over the
hardware and software of it and
talk about like the results how we
analyze the data and a little discussion
on the significance of it and of course
if we have time i also want to um give
you a very very quick overview of some
of the other research that we're doing
in the culture projects and where we
want to take the direction of this
research so
to start out i actually grew up about 30
minutes from here right in the heart of
the finger lakes um right uh
anyway it's about 30 minutes north here
and
for
my first job ever for five years was
working um in
uh a vineyard sunrise it was about five
minutes from where i grew up
um and so that was my childhood just
going out attending the vines and
learning how to grow grapes
and after that i went on to study
physics and computer science and um
and then went to industry and got a job
as a systems engineer no one knows what
systems engineering is that's alright i
came to cornell and uh i was fortunate
enough to join the cures peterson
peterson's lab as a phd student uh she
runs the collective body and development
stuff so that's a little bit about me um
now i know you guys are mostly uh
science people so you already have a
really good idea of like agriculture and
why it's important to study it
but i thought i would just sort of throw
some things out there for you like the
world population is growing and it's
growing fast right and
that means that we're going to need more
food for uh to eat meat uh
hungry right and uh particularly um
we
wanna work on nutrient-rich foods right
things that are going to actually
help people grow strong and
you know develop developmentally
um
and one of the one of the problems with
this is that farming over the past 12
years has been
notoriously like unprofitable so so on
the one hand you have increased demand
for food and on the other hand we have
uh it's becoming less and less
profitable to become a farmer right and
so these these problems are kind of um
are kind of clashing together to
exacerbate things and so we're left with
like a global global food story people
are going hungry um
and so that's this is kind of like
motivation for like why i'm interested
in agriculture at all right and uh
so like to give you an overview of
robotics and technology in agriculture a
lot of these technologies they start out
in the lab right
you've got cutting edge like computer
vision machine learning um
you know automation things like that and
at some point um
they have to move out of the lab and
into the field where a farmer can
actually use this technology to help
them do their job though right and that
has like a local impact
right you can
help them reduce waste create higher
yields increase profit margins uh things
like that
and when you take a bunch of small farms
right that are all
able to have access to this technology
and you look at the local impacts um
when you zoom out this overall can have
a huge global impact right and help meet
the hunger crisis increase
sustainability things like that so um
the area of my research is kind of like
right here in the middle like how do we
get the technology
out of the lab all of this great cutting
edge stuff that engineers are coming up
with how do we get it out of the lab and
maybe that fans or farmers to a point
where they can actually use it they
don't need a degree in engineering in
order to figure out how to operate
mechanisms um or understand the
principles but we can actually
disseminate that technology to help them
improve their management process
so um looking a little bit more closely
like local little culture um
like the great industry in the us is
pretty big right and more specifically
it's a very important industry to new
york not only in like direct crate sales
and wine sales but it brings a
tremendous amount of tourism to this
area like um my family member i have a
brother-in-law who's a winemaker in this
area like
his living is from people coming to the
finger lakes to try local wine right and
and one of the challenges
is that um bill prediction is pretty
hard right like just an anecdotal
example in 2016 we had a really big
drought the following year in 2017 um
most of the yield predictions only
accounted for about like two-thirds of
the final harvest yield so like
people have a really hard time
estimating exactly how many grapes
they're going to get at the end of the
year which will be really problematic um
and so like why
are we interested in predicting yields
and years in the first place and the the
short answer is resource output right
like
uh farmers need to secure tank space or
grape juice and turn it into applying
they need to secure you know bottles
label packaging stuff like that um they
also need to
secure a labor which can be very
difficult a lot of laborers like
micro fiber workers things like that you
need to secure them ahead of time and uh
they they secure them for a certain
amount of time like a week or two right
and if it's going to take substantially
longer to harvest everything or prove
everything that they initially thought
like you need to know that kind of thing
ahead of time
um
and of course uh probably one of the
most important things is sale and
purchase agreements so like um
every year
uh
vineyards that don't have a winery they
have to find wineries to buy their
grapes and every year wineries that
don't have enough vineyards to make wine
or all the wine they're trying to
produce
they have to
find sellers to buy the grapeshot and so
like they make agreements about how many
tons of grapes they're going to buy each
and like knowing ahead of time if you're
going to have like 10 tons of groups
from a certain block or 15 tons of
grapes from a certain block can make a
really big difference when you're trying
to negotiate these things from a
business standpoint
and the biggest thing here is that like
uh like i said before yield is really
hard to predict and one of the reasons
why is because there's a very large
amount of punctuation in the amount of
rain that you get
so like out in california it's very dry
everything is irrigated they can
precisely water uh all of the vines as
much as they want and they can get the
same yield every year out of the same
amount of uh
up here like
in 2007 we got like eight inches of rain
this is just for the summer months and
then in 2021 we got like 25 inches right
so like vast differences in the amount
of rain can change um yield pretty
tremendously so it's just like a really
hard problem to solve right so that's
why we're motivated to try and uh
predict yield and figures
so i'm just going to go over this pretty
quickly this is a this is a grapevine um
if you hear me talk about shoots
every grapevine has like a trunk
it grows up from the ground and then
anywhere between two to four canes that
run along a wire and off of those things
there's a vertical road called a shoot
all of the great clusters grow directly
off of the shoot
so and then sometimes you'll hear when
you refer to like a shoot tip it's like
um
early on in the season before the vine
goes to its full capacity the tip of the
shoot has this nice light green rope at
the end of it that um
you'll see in some of the pictures that
i show later um that's pretty easy to
recognize
so i'm just going to be referring to
streets and clusters and two tips i just
um wanted you guys to have an
understanding for what i'm talking about
so this is just another picture of like
um the way that these are the chains
there's anywhere between two to four
depending on how healthy the mind is and
the
the shoots go off of the queens and the
clusters for all issues
so um how do we estimate yield in a
venue and i promise there's not a lot of
math in this this talk this is this is
about the extent of it um
like the estimate in time and tons tons
of grades if you will just like the
number of grape clusters in the vineyard
times the average weight of each three
clusters pretty straightforward right
um
so no farmer is going to count the total
number of great great clusters in their
entire menu because that's just kind of
ridiculous so what we do instead
is we break this chart into future and
we talk about like the average number of
grapes per line
and then multiply that by the estimated
number of lines
and so there's sort of two factors if
you will um the total number of vines in
the vineyard is pretty well known or
understood like um you can even do this
on a panel by panel basis which would be
like a group of three or four lines
between the posts
um and so like the two main factors that
farmers are always trying to figure out
then when estimating you this one right
here which is like the number of great
clusters per vine or per panel
and the weight of each period
um pretty straightforward stuff right so
this project is
focused on only estimating that first
term the total number of grapes in the
vineyard um
we have other ways of estimating the
average rate cluster
you can use historical data right how
much influence your cluster weigh last
year
phase lag method involves like looking
at uh how heavy the grape is at a
certain point of the
growth of growth cycle and then using
that to extrapolate
uh growing degrees they method actually
accounts for like weather and sunlight
and stuff like that um there's not just
to do this i'm sure there's room for
improvement but that's not what i'm
focused on right now what i'm focused on
right now is estimating um
the number of great clusters for mine
actually more specifically the total
number of great clusters in the figure
because farmers they estimate the
average number of great questions
by manually counting all of the great
clusters on like a subset of the vines
in the mean right and they calculate an
average and they call it good enough of
course this has some problems because um
the accuracy of this estimation is going
to
the amount of
data that you the amount of vines that
you have to count in order to get an
accurate average is going to scale with
the size of the figure right if you've
got a small 12-acre and you might be
able to get away with counting 100 bucks
right but if you've got you know 120
acres in here that might not be good
enough right so one of the problems is
like how much
data is enough data to give yourself a
good estimation there's also other
content this can be expensive right if
you have a large end you're going to
have to trap a larger subset
there's also this this issue of like
buying selection bias which can be kind
of challenging because
uh the robustness of the vine is going
to depend a lot on like where it is in
the vineyard so if you've got like a
little valley where all the rain cells
and the nutrients
and soil sodium it kind of like settles
in that valley
you might have like six or seven vines
that are really full and really robust
and then
uh and then you know like a couple feet
away you'll have these little scrawny
vines that don't have the same nutrients
right and so
you could imagine that if you selected
just only the healthy vines you're gonna
have you're going to wait over estimate
an average number of great clusters per
high and vice versa right so like
selecting the right sub sample of lines
and this last one is huge counter error
people are
are
very unreliable and consistently
counting a number of great questions for
vine and we i'll show you that uh
oh this is just a picture of like the
vines and um
it's kind of actually hard to see the
great posters you can't count them by
just sort of walking by and looking at
them you have to like
put your hands in the vine touch every
single shoot of which there are hundreds
on a single line you have to figure out
exactly how many
clusters are on that shoot and you can't
double count and you can't underground
right it's really hard to do this uh
that's why that's why like
um manual accounting can be shown alive
so
just to illustrate how unreliable manual
content can we took data over uh three
years
uh in 2020 we just have one person count
those are the yellow dots so
um
on the x-axis here we have the harvest
house the harvest counts are considered
like the sort of the ground truth the
most reliable comedy great customers are
actually interviewed the reason why is
because when you're harvesting you're
going through and you're cutting off
each grade cluster by hand you're
counting it and putting it in a bit
you can't double count because once
you've cut it off you can't count it
again right it's no longer on behind and
hopefully you're not missing any great
busters when you harvest so that's why
we consider the harvest pound sort of
like the ground truth um and so what we
have here are hand counts that were
taken in early june
um like you can see this person who
counted with the yellow dots they had a
relatively straight line
um with some variants and a pretty high
r2 value r2 is just like you know how
well it all fits
to the line getting like this person in
2020 did a fairly good job if you look
at the two counters that we've had in
2019
um
it kind of just
it almost looks like they randomly
picked the number you know what i mean
there's not there's not much of a line
view to speak of uh and you can even see
that like the rt value fits for for
these years so like
and and this is the difference between
you know like a highly motivated grad
student from united department working
with us doing a really good job and like
some summer interns that
you know like it's just really
inconsistent about like how well
someone's going to do when it comes to
so hopefully that makes sense um
so i also just want to touch base on
this real quick
we also threw around the idea of instead
of counting great clusters
um
themselves what if we counted the shoots
use the number of shoots as a proxy kind
of hoping that it would be easier to
find a consistent uh
it'd be easier to find an average number
of brake posters per shoot
and then count the shoots then on each
line that it would be to find the
average number of great clusters per
vine hopefully that makes sense and the
reason why is because like if you just
sort of plot the average number of
questions in the average number of
shoots you do get a really a relatively
nice training so i'll talk about that
more in a bit
these two graphs are just to illustrate
we have
one counter
count all of this all of the clusters
and shoots out on a set of lines and we
had another counter go back and count
them
and if they got the same count
you would expect a nice straight line
and what we haven't said is that the two
different people got two very different
numbers fantastic so
just kind of illustrate exactly how hard
and difficult it is
the question is can we improve upon this
process right
and the way we do that hopefully is by
like reducing the amount of uh
counting that people have to do like if
you know that you have to count a
thousand lines you're going to do it
very quickly you're probably not going
to do a very good job if you know that
you only have to cut 10 lines right or
20 lines that kind of it's going to
change your approach you can be much
more precise you can take your time
you're more at your account um
and of course if you're counting less
you're reducing the amount of time that
you have to face underneath
which means you're saving money
um and so can we create a system that
that will reduce the amount of rating
accounts that we have to do it'll it'll
be low cost easy to use right
um and ultimately will perform better
than a traditional members account right
so um
that's why i want to propose this new
computer vision method uh which is
basically just a smartphone
attached to a tractor um or
uh
or
or could be walked through the video so
so basically what we have here is this
uh a smartphone the camera is pointing
at the device and it automatically
counts the number of brake clusters and
then we just count manually count a
small subset of the device in order to
calibrate them to make sure that we're
not that we can account for any
occlusion or like great clusters that we
can't see um and it's actually really
cheap to do right most people already
any smartphone maybe not for 2016
probably has a camera good enough to be
able to do something like this
and we use some lights that cost 50
um with some batteries and stabilizing
the gimbal that you can just like
pick up from walmart that cost eighty
dollars right like this whole setup you
know costs
under two hundred dollars and um
hopefully improve upon the the
methods and so i'll get into that in a
bit do you have any questions i just
wanna
okay cool
um
so here's just an example of how it's
set up this is a atv uh this is a tripod
there's a little gimbal right here and
there's my there's my phone my
like at this point six-year-old phone
now or something like that it's just
an iphone 10. uh here's another shot of
it you can see we have some led lights
and
here's just an example of the video now
it looks like i'm driving really really
slow i'm not i'm driving at a reasonable
pace um
i took the video and slowly and i'll
kind of explain why in a bit
but
my camera can do 240 frames per second
uh like i said my phone is relatively
old
so
um
so here's just another diagram kind of
like illustrating what we're doing here
driving through the vines the camera's
out i recorded 240 frames per second uh
the reason i do this at night with
artificial lighting is because
from a computer vision standpoint from
an engineering standpoint it's a lot
easier to create detection algorithms
tracking algorithms that have consistent
lighting positions
you could do this during the day
and i'm sure that some companies would
take this and
re-implement it to make it work during
the day i just don't have the time to
create that much training data and
fine-tune the algorithms
it just sort of simplifies things to do
it at night a lot of farmers actually
like to do their spraying at night
because the wind drops down right around
sunset
um
so
and then of course there's just a gimbal
that
when you go over bumps or whatever the
cable just kind of stabilizes the camera
so the camera isn't shaking um
so that's pretty much the
main thing but but this isn't the first
computer vision system to attempt to
predict yields the question is like why
is this different than anything anyone
else has done and there's a couple
reasons the first is it's they're cheap
um
there are people who have built stereo
machine learning computer vision systems
to do something like this yeah they do
it a little bit you know substantially
better than we do but they cost 12 000
a farmer growing you know
30 acres of freeze is not going to be
able to invest 12 000
into an advanced computer vision system
when they're only going to be saving
themselves
maybe five or six grand um
by accurately estimating their really
high right so
no specialized hardware it's a lot
cheaper um it's pretty easy to use all
you need is a phone and you need to just
find some way to like
strap it to a tractor um or even just
like hold your phone and walk through
the vineyard which i thought too
and uh
one of the differences here is that we
actually look at the vines much earlier
than a lot of other fields field
prediction methods too so we're looking
at the fine sharing uh
icon
laurent stages 12 through 15 which
are kind of in here right so the grape
cluster it's like right before they
start to flower uh the grape clusters
are a little bit bigger than my thumb
they're very small they're very hard to
detect um
but the canopy the leaf area is much
thinner so a lot of other
people who do this kind of research
they kind of cheat at what they do as
they go through and they rip off all the
leaves
and i've seen pictures of it in like
papers and stuff and it's just kind of
unrealistic you might do something but
but
we can just sort of go in
uh leave the vines as they are we don't
have to artificially like remove leaves
in order to make the great customers
more visible and uh
when they're
about the size of uh
so
um before variation
uh so
this is just a quick overview of like
the software side of it like how we
analyze the videos um and i'll explain
it conceptually and then go into some
components a bit more just to
give you guys a bit of a background so
we start by taking the frames from the
video individually
take the frames from from the video
individually and put them into an object
detection algorithm this is what your
phone uses or facebook uses to like
detect the face except instead of trying
to protect your face with the typewriter
cluster pretty straightforward uh we
take the location of those very clusters
we pass them into visual trackers
additional tracker basically can take um
you can take subsequent frames of a
video and when you put a box around
something it can try to find that object
in the next frame
um without and all it knows is where it
was in the previous trip so i can kind
of like follow objects through the video
and what this does is it allows us to
not double countdowns or double count
break clusters so let's say in one frame
it detects um a great cluster and then
in the next frame we detect it again the
visual tracker is going to estimate the
position of that very cluster from the
previous rank in the new frame and when
they line up it'll be like oh here you
detected that great cluster we don't
need to detect it again so then at the
end of it all you have to do is like
count the number of trackers you have
and you have an estimate for the number
of great clusters in the row or the
panel or the vineyard or whatever
pretty straightforward um so
this is what it ends up looking like uh
at the end
you can see there are little boxes being
drawn around these great clusters um
numbers and
uh i'm gonna kind of like follow the
great clusters as they move through the
thing as they move through the shot once
again it's moving pretty slowly that's
only because i slowed the video down
this video over here i um
uh it's not in slow motion you can see
instead of counting the grape clusters
i'm actually trying to count
the shoe tips instead right hoping that
we can use these shoots as a proxy for
the number of great thrusters uh so this
is a bit closer to the actual speed that
uh i was moving with the tractor um
so
yeah this is this is how it performs um
now i'm going to go a bit into
how the object detection and trackers
work i'm going to keep things as
conceptual as possible but i just want
to help you guys understand that like
object detection it isn't black magic
it's actually a very basic map
i'm not going to go into the map don't
worry but i just want you guys to not be
like next time you read about object
detection just have an understanding of
like what's happening uh inside the box
so
let's see okay so
what's another neural network is like
just a mathematical algorithm um it's
made up of a bunch of perceptrons and
this up here is is a perceptron and all
perceptron does is it takes
a bunch of numbers that are in a line
it takes each of those numbers it
multiplies them by another number adds
them together
and then once it adds them together it
figures out if the total is
bigger or smaller than some threshold
and if it's bigger the output of that
perceptron is a one it's smaller the
output of that perceptron is zero and
what this simulates is a neuron in the
human brain that has some electrical
inputs and decides whether or not to
fire like the synapse right
so what you can do is you can string a
bunch of things like each of these dots
here is like its own perception you can
string a bunch of these perceptrons
together and you get a neural network
that mimics brain behavior because all
it's doing is um figuring out based on
the inputs whether or not it needs to
fire right
and it isn't
uh older neural networks used to just
sort of be a one or a zero output um
we've kind of updated them now to have
like
a scale between one and zero so they can
kind of on that fire and like i said
it's just designed to limit like
synapses firing in your brain you can
strengthen synapse connections or weaken
synapse connections in order to learn
things
so the beauty of this algorithm is that
if you give it examples of what you
wanted to learn the algorithm can
automatically figure out what numbers it
needs to multiply by the inputs
at each level in order to give you the
desired output
right so like i said it's very powerful
because you can just give it examples i
want you to learn how to do you know
even these sets of inputs you need that
output you give it a bunch of examples
eventually it just figures it out in its
own feels like a real human brain
one of the challenges is that um
it's only designed to take 1d data
images of course are 2d so the question
is how do we overcome this and the
answer is instead of coming up with like
a line of numbers multiplied by your
line of inputs you basically come up
with a square of numbers like a grid of
numbers to multiply by your input and uh
that way you can just take two
dimensional chunks of the image and do
the same thing um
we uh
we stopped calling them perceptrons at
that point we start calling them filters
and we just have cascading functions
that act a lot like perceptrons and they
just take chunks of the image and
multiply by some number adds them onto
the next set of filters and if you do
that enough you end up with something
this is just sort of a visual
representation of what it is it ends up
being like a set of
high level features when i say high
level features i mean like
edges corners
curves waves color patterns things like
that it's like it's like a abstraction
of what's in the image except it's kind
of spatially corresponding to where that
feature is in the image and then we just
take those features we put them into a
regular
2d neural network and out
pops you know you pass in a picture of a
cat or a picture of a dog and it says oh
this one's a cat this one's a dog let me
stay forward right
hopefully um that makes sense to you
guys
um
going for one more sliding here and
basically
these types of neural networks are
called convolutional alarm numbers
they're really good at classifying an
image as what it is but they're hard at
figuring out where on an image something
is
and so for that um
basically what they do is they just put
a bunch of
convolutional neural networks together
they put them together in an order where
they one convolutional neural network
comes up with features another
convolutional neural network tries to
guess what what
parts of the feature probably have
objects in it and then there's another
one over here that just takes each of
those proposed locations and determines
if it's a grid cluster or not so pretty
straightforward um
that's how that that was uh that was
from like this section over here i'm
also just going to briefly explain the
tracker to you i know this image is a
bit
hard to understand uh i just pulled it
from our paper but i'll explain to you
conceptually
the tracker is basically what they do is
they just um
every time a new frame comes up we have
a
we have a
bunch of boxes around all of our grape
cluster the tractor just um extrapolates
the previous previous grade clusters to
the new location
lines them up with the new detections
figures out which ones are the same and
which ones are unique and puts boxes
around the ones that we haven't detected
yet and assigns a number to them and the
ones that we have already detected it
just assigns the old number to that new
detection does that make sense and that
way we can avoid double counting um and
stuff like that we also throw a few
tricks in there to try and figure out
what to do when like a grape cluster
moves behind the leaf and then comes
back out the other side because the
tracker can't follow it behind the leaf
so we use some like velocity
extrapolation things like that
point being the tracker basically just
tries to maintain the identity of its
great cluster as it comes in and out
so hopefully that makes sense and so
that's
sort of this step right here and uh
that's that's pretty much it i i you
guys now understand how all of the
computer vision magic works um you know
uh inside the black box so
uh here are the the results basically um
so
this graph up here is what i showed you
um before this is what
what happened when we asked people to go
through and manually count
all of the great clusters in every
section of the vineyard and they counted
them on a panel by panel basis which i
think is a group of four lines
so each point represents like how many
grape clusters are in that before
um and so
yeah so up here you can see over the
over the course of three years
um sort of like how well they correlated
to the actual wheel
we also asked them to go through and
manually count shoots to see if when
they counted shoots there was a strong
correlation to the yield
you can see what's going on there now
these two columns over here are
basically the same counts except
generated by
sparkling
uh instead so um
so uh and here just uh our two values
just to give you a sense of how strong
they correlate um
what basically what we can see is like
it's it's it's about as good as the
manual right um the difference is you
can do it substantially faster with your
phone than you can with
um by hand
but one of the problems we have is that
the phone pretty regularly under
accounts by a certain percentage because
there are there's a certain percentage
of grade clusters that you can't see on
the back side of the line and so
um the way the
way we overcome that is by uh
a row for example we have a certain
account that the computer vision
uh
algorithm gives us for let's say three
of those panels we go through manually
cut three of those panels and figure out
how much they're off and we just correct
them and we use that correction factor
to correct all the rest of the data
from all the rest of the videos that we
recorded
so hopefully that makes sense
so in analyzing our data what we did is
we randomly subsampled the manual counts
let's say there was 100 channels that
were manually counted we would choose 20
of them we took those 20 and we tried
and we came up with an average number of
clusters per panel panel using the
manual counts which is like this number
here
we also took those same 20 and we
decided to use them as calibration data
for our smartphone so we can calibrate
all of the video guides and so we're
trying to figure out is like
which is better just counting the manual
set by itself and using that as an
average or counting manual subset and
then calibrating the videos and then
using the videos to solve something
requested
um and what we did was we did that like
a couple thousand times because um i had
we encountered the entire vineyard by
hand so i randomly chose a subsample
um just
arbitrarily a large number of times and
each time we're going to get a
prediction from the manual method and
the prediction from the automated method
and sometimes it will be accurate
sometimes will be off really depends on
[Music]
distributions of hair
here
and so um
on the left side we've got like our
automated uh automated estimations and
then on the right side we've got the
manual estimations and what's important
to note here is that um
that both both methods are prone to
error right and there are times when
like you want to be as close to zero as
possible basically that means you
estimated the total in your fields
accurately
there are times when you know a certain
percentage of the time
manual methods did get it exactly right
but on average you can see that the
automated methods they've reduced your
range of error pretty tremendously right
so like you got like the worst case
error you know um
over here you know this ranges from
negative 20 to over 30 imagine just
being 30 off in a worst-case situation
right using that same data in your
smartphone we can actually reduce the
absolute worst pc
error to less than 20
right so
um hopefully this makes sense the idea
is we want to like mitigate how wrong we
can be by augmenting our manual accounts
with these smartphone
accounts and
we also did it with sheets
i guess i guess what we found was that
in general like trying to count the
number of clusters directly using the
phone ended up outperforming um all the
rest of the metrics so i'm going to show
you this table there's a lot of stuff in
here i threw it in here just
but the important things are right here
like
uh
like you can see compare these numbers
directly this is like the mean absolute
error this is like what percentage off
of the total yield for each of these
methods and we reduced our
on average we reduced our error by about
two percent um
which
which uh
this is in 2020 so if you remember back
to the graph of manual tests the person
who catches manually in 2020 actually
did a really good job but we're still
able to edge them out by about two
percent right if you look at uh 2019
where the manual accounts were kind of
all over the place
our our margins were a lot higher right
they were the two different patterns you
know we're at eight and a half and six
percent we knock that down to three
percent
right
so um
one of the important takeaways is like
yes we do better on average over the
when you look at the four wings but
um we also do better on like a fine by
time basis so for example
if you're manually counting the vineyard
and you
manually count
half of your vines
20 over and the other half of your vines
20 under
you're gonna average out to zero
right
um
but
in reality you were 20 off the entire
time you just kind of got lucky that you
averaged out correctly right
what this automated method does is
because we're
because we're imaging the entire block
of grapes
um
our error on a vine by line basis which
are kind of represented by the mean rms
and the mean um
absolute error columns here our error on
a line-by-line basis ends up being
much smaller right so basically what i'm
trying to say is like we can better
capture the variance on a line-by-line
basis throughout the vineyard than a
simple mean or a simple average
and that's what makes this i think
just better than
what farmers have been doing basically
ever since they started trying to
estimate
so hopefully this makes sense um
so
there's a couple important things to
think about here the first is that like
i said before as your vineyard gets
bigger if you're trying to do this
manually
you're going to have to keep counting a
larger and larger area
however with one method
all you have to do is like record
more of a larger venue which is pretty
easy to do especially if you're driving
through the video anyways to fertilize
or spray pesticides you just have to put
your phone out there and the phone will
do all of the work and you can only
count a small section of the vines to
calibrate instead of having to
um keep count like
uh keep counting a large in order to
section it because then you're able to
get bigger right so
um just to sort of illustrate that this
red section here this is like this is
like the the sort of the error band
using the automated method when we only
use 20 panels for calibration and these
bars here are like the number of panels
we use to estimate using the manual
method and so
what you can see is that it takes about
it takes about 50
panels
using the traditional method to
estimate to get the same accuracy as
when we use 20x right
50 pedals versus 20 pounds it doesn't
seem like a lot but
we did like less than an acre in this
experiment right
uh when you consider the fact that it
takes about if you're really good and
really fast it takes about 15 minutes
per panel um to count them manually and
you consider that there are about 160 to
200 panels per acre depending on the
variety and the average vineyard size of
the finger legs is 40 acres
this time difference
um
you can actually get like a hundred
percent uh sorry 100 times decreasing
the amount of labor needed to get the
same estimation in your accuracy so
um hopefully this makes sense the idea
is that like
for what we're doing just like
various like less than an acre the
differences were noticeable but as you
try and scale this up to a larger and
larger vineyard
um your cost savings grow like
exponentially right as opposed to sort
of like the same percentage so um that's
like that's the
main hope is that like we can
create a tool right that allows farmers
to
get better yield estimates with a lot
less effort than they would otherwise be
able to do
um so hopefully this thing since you
guys have any questions
next yeah if you have any questions
before i uh
[Music]
yeah all right no
questions i really like the innovative
devices and the algorithms but
i have a question so you mentioned there
are some alternative methods which cost
really a lot and what do you think what
is the difference between your method
like in terms of algorithm or devices
like what is the difference from that
yeah so the main um
the main other uh researcher
his name is exceeding my mind who does
yield prediction in videos he started a
cornell moved down to running melon
i've seen his mechanism
the camera itself
is massive
and
it's a very
very expensive
stereo like 3d camera that uses like
back scattering of x-rays
um and like you need this huge
metal mechanism to like properly mount
it to a tractor
uh
it's just huge and expensive and
you have a hard time finding a vineyard
manager who would want to spend 12 000
on a piece of equipment like that so you
have a 12 000 piece of equipment hanging
off the part of their tractor
so that they can improve their yields
um so like that's sort of the biggest
stuff yeah their algorithms are more
advanced because they're doing full
reconstruction
um they're they're using x-ray max
scatter
and they're uh gps integration and
they're kind of like generating these 3d
uh images of the vines uh we took a much
more basic simpler approach because
we're not trying to create the best and
the brightest and the fastest but we're
trying to create something that farmers
are actually going to want to use right
and we'll actually help them today right
uh i could i could pull my phone out
it's a little late
but three months ago i could pull my
phone out right through the vineyard and
uh i don't need a 12 000 piece of
equipment so from an algorithm and
hardware standpoint it's just a lot
simpler um
but
from a usability standpoint it's much
more accessible
that's a great question so i actually i
knew i was beginning to put something
about presentation
[Music]
uh i mean i just pulled my phone out use
the camera app on my phone um so it's
not hard at all but we're trying to fit
in after that
will
also integrate
gps location so the farmers not only
know what the yield is but they can have
a heat map of the wheel to figure out
exactly where the yield is
which can help with fertilizing and
things like that and then uh
ideas that will be connected to like a
club a base back end
we're also looking at possibly other
routes of commercialization um
you know there have been a few companies
that have reached out that are
interested in
licensing
um so
we're kind of in that process of like
working to get it out to the farmers
right now
that's a great
[Music]
in real time
it happens uh
i just load the videos on my computer
hit a button software processes them
output you can batch process video files
in excel file with the name of the video
file and the big questions
[Music]
and i used off-the-shelf
neural networks because
pre-trained neural networks because i
wanted to minimize the amount obtaining
data that i needed to generate to help
it protect great group but if you wanted
to commercialize this
you could especially with modern
smartphones that have chips that are
that are optimized for network
computations
you probably would with a good deal of
effort couldn't make this run on the
phone um or at the very least make it
just substantially more efficient from a
computer standpoint um
this is the type of thing that you can
process for a few dollars
you know
is foreign um
open source neural network platform
great question that's a very good
question um so
the answer is we didn't we didn't
research that extensively but we did do
this um
2020 the 2020 data was performed on two
different
varieties riesling and pinot noir
and
i ran some experiments where i
i
i measured the performance of a neural
network trained on recent data
on videos from community one to see like
do i need more training data in order to
get this work on a different variety and
the answer is no
uh we're we are
taking videos so early in the season
that pretty much every variety looks the
same
all of the great clusters in the same
shade of green and they're all about the
size of my phone so like that's one of
the advantages here is like
uh
like i said if you haven't tested this
thoroughly but like from the from the
bit of investigating so far it seems
rather agnostic to at least the great
varieties that we tend to grow up here
in upstate new york that being said
expanding into other great varieties um
could just be uh
creating a bit more training for the
neural nerves um there might be some
issues with occlusion in other varieties
that you
aren't dealing with in these but um
but yeah so hopefully that answers your
question
um so i image both sides of mine just to
compare them and uh when you're
calibrating the data using manual
accounts you don't actually need both
sides
um
you might get a slightly better estimate
if you take both sides and average them
or something like that but this stuff i
think i just used
[Music]
i want to take a step back so
because the the video is
taken so earlier
the
the precipitation or greenhouse
variation from years that is really
clear
so
how that's a factor because the initial
motivation is
that being said the overall size of the
vine
is going to be affected by like the
moisture levels early on in the year so
like winter snowfall
um
water absorption in like april uh
you know march april that period of time
just kind of effect basically like
how many how many uh
uh how many shoots to grow up and then
like i said um
[Music]
like the uh the number of
sheets
um
the number of shoes in
so
a healthy year with a lot of rainfall
what they do
these shoots sorry these canes
are actually
last year's shoots from the inside of
the vine
hopefully that makes sense they choose
like the four best shoots near the
center of the bike they cut everything
else off they take those shoots they lay
them down as things
if you've got a lot of rainfall in a
given gear
um you're gonna have really big healthy
shoots in the middle of the vine those
are going to make your really good canes
the following year does that make sense
so
and then remember the shoots broke next
year's shoots grow directly off the
chains is because the clusters throw off
the shoes
if you only have two canes here instead
of four you're gonna have to yield on
that five
so
um
so like the rainfall from one year can
actually affect how many canes you're
going to have on your mind the next year
which
which severely impacts the amount of
field on that particular
um
that particular
does that make sense kind of answer your
question so like
some of this like early season rainfall
um a lot of it's like last year's
rainfall you know uh and like
and like how many kings you're going to
end up with things like that there's a
lot of factors um
yeah
to the next play
so how the room call you like the savior
that means if the current year has been
for influences
but the previous year
so so
yeah the current year rainfall during
the summer mostly impacts this the
rainfall
of the current year
prior to
um
prior to
[Music]
like the great clusters developing will
affect
this number for the current year but
this number is going to be most affected
by how many kings there are left over
from the previous group so
um it's it's a bit of vote although
if that makes sense so the rainfall kind
of early in the current growing season
is going to affect the number of great
clusters but it's also a number of grain
clusters is also affected by last year's
rainfall
this term is what's mostly affected by
the current year's rainfall but this
term is effective
in your early later um analysis you show
uh
your automated
approach versus manual approach
the comparison was based on yield so
it's not the
the comparison was against the number of
great clusters counted during the
harvest period
so we weren't comparing it against the
weight
we were actually what we did was we
attempted to calculate this number at
the beginning of this season and then we
precisely counted this number when we
were hearts
does that make sense um
so
so yeah we didn't we didn't at any point
compare our estimates for this against
against
the whole term but rather during the
harvest process we went through and
maybe we counted the number of
requesters during the harvard process um
and came up with a more accurate
competition
yeah okay
so
okay i don't know maybe i'm confused
because in
we normally in science we
put the
predictor value of the variable as those
as the x-axis and the response variables
the response variable is the actually
yield right
so
so the counts what you have on the
y-axis is your account with division
system um
the y-axis is the constant division
system right
the x-axis is like the ground truth
it's not a response as much as it is
i graph uh an estimate against the truth
okay does that make sense so like the
idea is that if our estimate is perfect
all of the dots can be perfectly
straightforward
right so
when you look at state of the body
your
counts
range from
let's say
30 to 50 you know more or less i can
actually explain this to you yeah uh in
years 2020
somebody
uh
a paragraph student to go through and
take videos i didn't take videos myself
this particular year i heard a grad
student go through and take videos
and
when he took videos um
he got really close to the vine and he
cut off
in the frame all the tops
of the shoes
and so
the algorithm wasn't actually able to
detect any of the tips of the shoots
in those videos from that year that's
why this line looks so black
hopefully that makes sense
okay um yeah there's a huge range in the
actual and the very error
in the
uh
that's why we ended up going with this
uh with counting the posters
um it just like you said
this doesn't quite capture the variance
quite as well as
it might be worth calling up on that
sorry we're talking about
the one reason for that is an easy way
to record these videos but another
reason for that is to give some feedback
as they record it so we actually try
having other people uh pour data like
this in washington
um and we found that even though we felt
like we gave you very very clear
instructions and it's very very simple
they're still amazing for mistakes like
they would take it slightly too early it
doesn't die from the background when
they take it too close it's like here
and so what we're hoping the app can do
is give them feedback directly instead
of actually
actually
we'll go back
[Music]
and the fact that it responds
so the reason we
[Music]
um
um
some of the papers i've seen didn't
require working more holidays because
later in the season when the great
clusters have fallen through the ring um
elite canopy is much more dense it's
actually a lot harder to see it so we
basically just said like
where is there room for improvement and
we kind of focused in our research on
that number of questions apparently and
kind of left the other term to
whatever method the grower chooses or
what other people who were currently
researching that but
i understand
um so that is a very
uh it isn't something
it's a variable and uh
frankly it's it's not an insignificant
variable like it's important
it's at least i mean it's not the term
and there's there isn't a bit of
variance like there's a good bit of
variance in that term um
but we just decided to solve the other
problem
when you're
manually the number of clusters let them
again early season or is that late when
you're communicating
so when we manually count them we do it
at the same time we do the imaging in
june
these these counts down here are done
manually too but they're done during the
harvest process
um
i think i'm out of time i do have one or
two more slides just to sort of show
where we're trying to take this stuff
next
we're looking at calculating a revised
index using also simple computer
division methods the revised index is
basically a way to help farmers uh tune
their pruning process like i said
they take last year's shoots
these guys
these guys right here and they turn them
into next year's themes which are those
guys right there um and so the way we're
doing that is
um
i tried using some
uh
lidar and um trying to make progress on
that
that being said lidar is a relatively
new technology um that's just now
getting put in people's smartphones um
and so i was like well let's back up and
see if i can come up with something that
um is simpler so i just picked some like
cheap five dollar lasers that i found on
amazon strap them into a smartphone
holder and like kind of use some
um structured light type stuff um these
are what the videos look like just like
dots right and i was actually able to
generate a pretty good sienna
of like the vines during cream process
the idea is we'll use this to estimate
pretty weight which informs the robust
index which can inform
techniques um and lastly
this same idea of like object detection
and tracking i'm actually implementing
um on another project studying honeybees
pollinators are very important to
agriculture so we're trying to
understand behavior and um
so working with an entomologist uh in
our lab
eaters to
come up with a way to help study and
help study uh honeybees
but
the main goal of this project is
ultimately to create like a
uh abstract
uh framework for detection and tracking
um so that people can use it for
animals honeybees insects grape clusters
anything that they want so that's sort
of where my my research is going in the
future and
yeah um
i just wanted to say thank you for
listening uh very intensely it was
representing you guys and
you asked some really phenomenal
questions
thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu